we just say that it's really hard to
follow a talk on sex and power this
doesn't seem fair I think I got chosen
though because I show a unique ability
to what Deborah called have a low
capacity for thinking and a low capacity
for action I have to tell you that I've
been with Donald Trump on several
occasions and he's not a
multi-billionaire he is an example of
the power of promotion a self-promotion
it always bugged being in the real
estate I was a real estate developer for
a long time and I just didn't seem fair
but he started out with 200 million
dollars you know it's not like he's the
self-made guy so hair notwithstanding
then I have to give one quick story
about the disinhibition I worked for
some time with a very powerful guy and
we'd hold meetings and partway through
the meeting he had a bad back partway
through the meeting he would disappear
and lie on the floor you'd be sitting
there at the table and there would be
nobody on the other side and he said
just keep talking so you talk into space
and then the answer would come from the
floor you know and so funny I got kind
of tired of this whole thing I said what
the heck so I decided I'm just going to
go around and lie down on the floor next
to him so I figure this is my expression
of being powerful too so I lay on the
floor right next to him we talked
both of us speaking up into the air when
an assistant walked in the room we had
to describe what that was about
finally this last lecture I've always
had slides or tried to you know be a
little slicker in my presentation that
I'm gonna try to be tonight but I've
never left time for questions so what
I'm gonna try to do is blast through
what I have to say with no slides and
leave time for questions and I might do
some editing
at the end to cut things so I've gotten
rid of slides and I've gotten rid of
stories I have oh I have stories to
illustrate all the points that I would
like to make tonight but I'm gonna cut
those out I have to start out by saying
that I'm delighted with the opportunity
to address you tonight I'm a huge fan of
GSB students I think the world of you I
think you're going to make a big
difference and I learned to expect great
things from GSB grads after you graduate
I will follow your careers whether it's
with cards calls emails or by rumor or
hearsay I was walking through JFK
Airport the other day through the
security and I had somebody call out
professor Peterson and it was somebody
I'd had in a real estate class ten years
ago and while I didn't remember his name
I remembered that he sat in the upper
right hand corner and blew a cold column
as I understand it the concept of the
last lecture was pioneered in the 1960s
at Brandeis University as a way of
getting teachers to conclude what was
what is important in their work to draw
general conclusions and to present them
to students as if it were the last time
they would ever stand before them and I
think that's a very interesting
formulation a way of thinking about how
do you boil down what it is you've taken
out of your life's experience or your
studies and impart it to others in the
last lecture if you think about that if
somebody asked you to do that that's
kind of a daunting request if you
imagine standing before your peers or
people you like and admire and
concluding with what you think is the
real essence of your takeaways when I
worry about the fact that some of you
might actually heed what I have to say
tonight I'm comforted by the fact that I
really know this is coming from a
part-time lecturer
who teaches an obscure second-year
elective it's at the end of your second
year after a long day of classes during
the spring so I'm not too worried nice I
always think of Churchill who once
quipped at this at the at the site of a
thick document this report by its very
length defends itself against the risk
of being read I've given him a half
dozen or so of these last lectures and
none has been the same so I've clearly
not done a very good job of summarizing
what my takeaways in life are and the
best I can do is say this is kind of
what I'm thinking in 2006 it won't be
about clear heights or setbacks or enno
eyes or negotiating strategies or Monte
Carlo simulations or building
spreadsheets or anything like that all
of that is important and will have an
impact on your business careers but none
of it is worthy of a last hour together
I had a partner asked me when I came
here white are you going to give another
one of these last lectures and so I'll
just take a second and answer that
question for you I've been teaching here
for 14 years as was mentioned I started
out teaching a real estate course to
keep my mind off litigation that I was
involved in it was very debilitating it
was so debilitating that I didn't want
it to absorb my life but it was too
important to ignore so I decided to take
this what I thought would be a brief
interlude at the GSB and it's turned
into a really rewarding second career so
the last lecture is an extension of that
commitment to teaching is a brief aside
I would encourage any of you who may be
interested in teaching to do it it will
keep you connected with young people
will keep you connected to growing and
learning and the hustle and bustle of
the marketplace can sometimes drive away
some of the good things that happen here
Robert bolts 1966 play a man for all
seasons has a character an ambitious
young man by the name of Richard
rich who is counseled by Sir Thomas More
that he would be a good teacher and he
dismisses this by saying if I was who
would know it to which Sir Thomas More
replies and this is what has haunted me
since I first heard it you your pupils
your friends God not a bad audience that
the essence of mores response has kept
me juggling a fairly complex life to
come back here and it's been richly
rewarding thus I want to begin tonight
by thanking you for allowing me to be
with you at this time in your lives
thanking you for the invitation to be
here tonight and thanking you your
parents your friends and your mentors
for preparing you to be qualified to be
at this unique institution at this time
so with that as a preamble let me begin
by saying that I've mentioned to all of
my students that they should begin every
new activity they do by imagining
winning think about what winning would
be and do it it was enough detail that
will get it will get you over the rough
points that you're sure to encounter so
it would only be it wouldn't be fair if
I didn't tell you what winning would be
for me tonight I'll have accomplished my
objective in speaking to you tonight if
I get some of you to seriously consider
tweaking your launch trajectory in light
of tonight's discussion of values
integrity and trust with this
I would hope that some of you would make
a commitment to yourselves to get the in
the right frame of mind for this I want
you to fast forward 50 years imagine
yourself sitting here in Bishop
auditorium you're sitting next to the
same people take a second to look around
look to the left look to the right check
behind you
now imagine these same people with gray
hair bald pates thicker midsections same
people let me suggest how you'll feel
when that reality is upon you you're at
your 50th reunion you'll feel like you
were hit by a tree you'll feel like I
look by the way I looked a little worse
than I usually do my son who's here my
son and daughter but with us tonight
both sophomores at Stanford Ben and
Annie dropped me off at a parking lot
that right next to a big oak tree that
had a low-hanging branch I bounced out
of his car and walked right into the
branch so I looked a little worse but I
I do realize that I am older than I feel
and I always tell my wife that the worst
part about being this old as I'm now
married to a grandmother
so now that you've been transported
forward 50 years I mean she has a good
sense of humor so don't now they've been
transferred important forward 50 years
imagine asking yourself these questions
what have you done with the last 50
years that's a hundred thousand hours of
work life at least more importantly what
does it meant to you and to those you
love what will be the residue of del DS
efforts as you sit here tonight what
would you hope you could say in other
words what would winning be in life for
you
what would the perfect life be you know
I can't think I know I've told a few of
you this story but I can't think of the
perfect life without thinking of a story
of learn at hand who was the greatest
American jurist never to be appointed to
the US Supreme Court he was a federal
judge in the state of New York and he
was asked what a perfect day would be
and he said and he said well I'd sleep
in till late I'd be served breakfast in
bed I would be driven to the stadium and
a limousine the crowd would cheer when I
entered I score the winning touchdown
I'd be carried off on the shoulders of
my teammates I would go home and have a
leisurely bath and then I would go that
evening to a dinner where would be
assembled all the great minds of all
time and over the din I would hear a
voice shout out shut up Voltaire we want
to listen to learn at hand now that's a
Technicolor version you can imagine that
perfect day can't you well I want you to
imagine a perfect life that you can
report on in 50 years make it in
Technicolor and the reason I ask you to
construct this is because if you'll do
it at this stage as you know minor
tweaks at the beginning of a long
journey can have significant impact can
have a really important effect on where
you'll end up so I want you to think
about
taking the road of life this trail taken
only once it's particularly worth
imagining winning and do it in some
detail and particularly at inflection
points such as the one that you're
approaching is you graduate from the GSB
so my message tonight is that how
effective you are at leaving a lasting
mark or winning in your life having a
perfect life will be a direct function
of your values your integrity and the
trust you and gender in others so my
last lecture will be about your core
values your behavior around those values
and your ultimate trustworthiness this
therefore will determine the course of
your life the legacy you'll leave and
the good or harm you'll do over the next
half century now let me elaborate on the
relationship between values integrity
and Trust and then I'll close with some
idiosyncratic advice that I think is
rooted in those three concepts some
students have asked me if I'd needed to
compromise values in order to achieve
success to that I respond not only does
one not need to compromise values to
achieve success but if your values are
abandoned
there'll be an awful price to pay that
price may come in the form of cynicism
or becoming overly wary it may manifest
itself in broken relationships scandal
or constant strife or it may simply mean
that you feel shabby or diminished when
you make your 50th year reunion whatever
success you may achieve in your business
careers and I would expect that it'll be
impressive you'll leave a live a
shallower sadder less fulfilling life if
you compromise important values in
getting there
I brought these books tonight not to
recommend them to you but I'm I'm in the
midst of reading both of these books
about the Enron scandal the smartest
guys in the room and conspiracy of fools
and it's so clear to me what has
happened with compromising of values
with changing values with giving up one
thing for another
and what it's done to the lives of those
who are involved I'm not the first to
suggest that you start with your values
I think with Socrates that had engraved
over the temple at Delphi at the
beginning of all learning to know
thyself two thousand years later
Shakespeare had Polonius say to his son
Laertes do thine own self be true and it
must follow as the night the day thou
canst not then be false to any man so
how can you know yourself if that's the
beginning of all knowledge of
understanding these core values that you
have is that is the place that you need
to start to organize the perfect life
how can you know your so when I think of
that journey of discovery I think of
Lenny Skutnik and arlynn Williams do
these names mean anything to anyone in
here is there anyone here from
Washington DC
nobody from Washington DC there yeah all
right well you know the Arlen Williams
bridge does that mean anything to you
support the old Rochambeau bridge now
the 14th Street bridge that got renamed
and I'll briefly tell you the story of
how that bridge got renamed on Wednesday
January 13th 1982 air Florida flight 90
arrived from South Florida to turn
around and head back to Fort Lauderdale
it was a cold day there was snow the
plane was de-iced there were delays and
it's sat on the tarmac for 49 minutes
without being able to take up the pilot
decided that since they'd already been
delayed over an hour hour and a half
that he would take off and so he took
off it took an extra eight hundred yards
almost a half mile to take off the plane
rose to about 337 feet at which time it
began to mush it's unable to keep going
and curved around and landed hitting the
14th Street bridge and landing in the
icy Potomac broke through an inch of ice
and the plane quickly went below the
water 73 of the 79 passenger and crew
were immediately killed
and six people clung to the tail of this
plane because it was a snowy tough day
it was tough for ambulances to get there
or for helicopters rescue helicopters to
get there is these six people huddled
around this tail and tried to stay alive
the firemen and the police set up
barricades and barriers the people who
were there tried to throw things ropes
makeshift ways to fish these people out
of the water they were unable to go
finally the helicopter arrived
twenty-one minutes later and threw a
rope down pulled a person to the shore
came back and who was identified as a
bald-headed man or the sixth passenger
named unknown
took the rope and gave it to an injured
passenger the helicopter came back an
other time he again cut the rope and
again passed it to another passenger and
the final time that the helicopter came
around by then he had slipped under the
water is the only person to have drowned
in that we later found out his name was
Harlan Williams he was a bank examiner
from Atlanta Georgia 46 years old no
indication that this man would be a hero
before this it was also one of the women
that was hanging onto the tail section
got weaker and weaker and finally
floated off and had jet fluid fuel in
her eyes couldn't tell where she was and
she cried out help me with this Lenny
Skutnik who was a $14,000 a year clerk
in the Congressional Budget Office broke
through the rope lines tore off his
overcoat and jacket took off his shoes
and jumped in the water to save this
well how did they know did they know
that they had that that was a set of it
that there was a set of core values in
them that would provoke them to those
behaviors I don't think they knew that
going into that day any more than I
think I know how I would behave in that
or that I know how I would behave under
certain conditions it is our values
however
that will determine where we draw the
bright lines and where it when it's when
we're under pressure when there are
dilemmas often when things are equally
attractive or equally repugnant it is
our core values that will force us to
draw the bright lines and make the
decisions for those of you in the
auditorium who may think you know your
core values today
let me quote my favorite quote of all
times also from another jurist Oliver
Wendell Holmes he said I would not give
a fig for the simplicity this side of
complexity but I would give my life for
the simplicity the other side of
complexity thus it is with our values we
may know and think we know our values
today but it's when they're tested in
the crucible of life through experience
that our values emerge so it's still
it's worth considering in the still in
the calm in the pre battle moments
before you enter the fray but you'll
really discover your battles when you
get over your values when you get out
their suggestion I I think you should
write out a statement of values now even
though it they may change and you'll
discover a lot about them at least
you'll know what you want them to be and
you'll have a pretty darn good time
before they really are today if you'll
consider where you spend your time your
money and your thoughts those are your
real values your values will continue to
drive every choice you make in your life
they will determine the contours of your
life when you stay late at work to work
on a project rather than go to your
child's soccer game you've made a
statement of values when you work 90
hours a week they'll have made a value
judgment when you stay up too late
you'll have made a value judgment just
kidding
when a business develops a budget it's
making a series of value judgments when
it hires from the outside its expressing
values when it takes time to regularly
celebrate the accomplishments of its
people it's expressing values more
generally whenever we select between
compelling of mutually exclusive
alternatives we use our values as the
tiebreaker so you'll all deal with some
thorny dilemmas that will yield only to
a hierarchy of values that you've not
yet articulated your core values are
where you'll go under pressure when no
one is looking or recording your actions
they are your operating system the
software of your life that's running
24/7 behind the scenes so understand
them test them review your actions in
light of them while your expressed
values are open to any who would hear
them your real values your core values
are a half-open book for people to see
and when these diverge your Express
failures and your real values people
naturally will question legitimately
question your integrity whenever I ask a
group of people if they have integrity
or what anybody who doesn't have
integrity please raise their hand
you know nobody offers that and I think
that's because we think we have
integrity when our actions reflect our
values and indeed they do it's when they
diverge from our stated values that we
violated integrity an and also the word
is so loaded that nobody likes to admit
they don't have it but I would say that
real unassailable ever-present integrity
the kind that holds up in the dark even
when no one is looking can be tough to
claim means we are at one with ourselves
both our public and our private lives
our stated values and our observed
values are congruent
so I'm gonna do some editing on the
flight a couple more suggestions because
life is hard you're gonna have to make
hard choices which can challenge your
values to figure out what your values
are besides being in the crucible of
life living to age 60 we'd do a lot of
reading you can live a hundred lives if
you read and then don't be timid get
experience as soon as you can I used to
say throw yourself in swiftly moving
streams be entrepreneurial even if
you're in a big company or working as a
bank or a consultant think about being
an owner manager so finally how does
this relate to trust having clear values
core values having the integrity to make
your stated and values and your actions
the same Trust is important because we
don't trust people when we think they
don't have integrity if you would be
trusted do something that eliminates the
gap between your stated values and your
real values let me give you just a brief
exposition here on trust and I won't
take too long on this but even though I
love and respect my family members and
in one sense I completely trust them I
wouldn't trust my fourteen-year-old
daughter to drive me to work I wouldn't
trust my wife to fly me to the next
meeting I wouldn't trust my business
partner who's a lawyer to do surgery on
me so we we require more than just
character to trust we require competence
and confidence even competence isn't
enough they have to to be trusted
somebody has to be powerful
so character competence and power are
the three things that are required to be
trusted so in summary if you'd be an
effective leader no.1 articulate clearly
your core values eliminate any gap
between your claimed and lived values
except that this will only give you one
of Trust's preconditions and now become
competent and empowered if you'd be
trusted that's the essence of my last
lecture is to do those four things major
my time I want to just give you quick
bullet point advice that resides in that
formulation of values integrity and
Trust
unlike classroom takeaways these are
take it or leave it
aways they're a bit idiosyncratic and
they really just represent one person's
take on the world of work so here goes
if you can find a mentor early in your
career do so later on be one do more
listening than talking leaving the GSB
armed with the best Maps the world has
to offer for the territory you're about
to enter but they're merely maps and
maps are not the territory there are
people who know the territory there are
people full of street smarts they may
not be able to read your maps and you
may feel slightly superior because they
can't read your maps
however they have a wisdom born of
having walked the trails and have
experience so listen to them respect
them and learn from them develop a plan
for your life and do it soon
you would organize or finance a business
without a business plan so don't treat
your life as an ongoing case of first
impression come up with a blueprint you
can always change it don't really have
merely day today
lest you fritter away your enormous
potential as a part of setting goals
recognize that whatever summits you
choose to climb will mean you have to
eliminate others so you're gonna have to
make some hard choices my advice is to
pick the highest possible reasonable
peak you can always scale back you're
unlikely to scale up and I have examples
for all of these and I'm just cutting
them all out so we have time for a
question as you seriously contemplate
which is sent to make think broadly
about your life not just about your
career
your next job or even the next decade
think 50 years in thinking broadly in
making your plan take into account
Frederick beak nurse advice to find
meaning in your life you'll need to
discover three things a person to be
someone to love and a work to do I
rather than give examples of this I'll
simply assert that you're unlikely to
find balance true balance in your life
unless you have all three legs of the
stool that has to do with being loving
and working this Drucker Peter Drucker
says build on your strengths make your
weaknesses irrelevant don't spend time
trying to fix everything that's wrong
with you lest you neglect your natural
gifts
be wary of getting locked in too early
in your career if you fail to change
with things you learn you'll miss a lot
of growth your think your thinking will
involve with insights if you're anything
like me you'll discover the following
but the prowess that you developed in
school with analysis will yield to the
synthesis required of leaders your well
regarded and realm awarded facility with
words and concepts will be overwhelmed
by the imperative for action and your
interest with in and facility with
manipulating and managing things will
give way to how compelling are the
relationships in your life so that I've
boiled this down to the following
progression actions are greater than
words wholes greater than parts and
people greater than things a quick word
about each as far as actions what you do
from here on out will count more than
what you say you won't be able to talk
your way out of problems you've behaved
your way into in a world of spin you may
and with your skills you may be tempted
to wordsmith a mission statement declare
to craft a clever response to a thorny
question or to ensure that blame ends up
on another's doorstep unless you have
ambitions is a lifelong politician these
won't work
as far as holes these well-honed
analytical skills you have to will
you've developed will have to evolve
into ability and ability to connect the
dots I'm confident that you'll soon see
how everything is indeed connected and
with this you'll find great relief in
the expression all things considered
finally as regards people you'll find
that business is all about people my
simple advice recognize that people are
smart they'll know if you're a phony
they'll see through your techniques so
above all love them this is not so hard
once you recognize that love is a
decision if you love someone you'll
sacrifice for them if you love someone
you'll do what's in their interest even
when it's not convenient and as you make
sacrifices and do hard and inconvenient
things for other and he loved you
decided to give them will now transform
into a genuine and durable connection
you can turn this will compel trust and
require higher mutual commitments and
challenge your ability to live with
integrity this can be pretty painful
really I mean I'm not saying this is an
easy thing to do but it's sometimes
rewarding and it's almost always the
right thing to do then if you need to
fire people redirect them or even
intervene in their personal lives you'll
do so with confidence that comes from
having their interest at heart and if
they know your motivations they'll more
often than not accept your actions and
occasionally even be grateful for them
don't let your MBA get in the way of
your education particularly don't be
afraid that of work that some might view
beneath an MBA I spent a lot of my life
early life delivering papers washing
dishes selling vegetables mowing lawns
etc and all of these turned out to be
valuable workplace lessons give me
valuable workplace s lessons that HBS
forgot to mention in value experience
that goes along a little bit with
respecting people who may not be able to
read your Maps imagine taking a flight
when over the PA system comes today's
pilot has carefully studied the avionics
man with manuals she received very high
scores on her written exams and
graduated from the best training program
I'm sure you'll join me in wishing her
well on her first ever cockpit
experience that's how people may see you
as you take the left seat so before you
assume their controls right in the back
of the plane sit in the right-hand seat
front end load your career what you do
in the next decade will have a whole lot
to do with the course of your
professional life in my view it is worth
tilting out of balance
a little bit during this first decade
you have to decide what the right rhythm
is for you for some daily balance is
vital for others monthly or yearly
balance others a decade being out of
balance is okay think career more than
job jobs come and go the best ones build
towards something the worst ones steal
your time and energy consider how the
work you're about to do will lead to the
goal you have in life and will lead you
to give this 50-year report on the
perfect life don't evaluate your job
offers by promises of hype a great
work-life balance or whether or not
you're joining an in favor company a hot
industry or something your peers will
think it's cool although I will have to
say that I did take a job on the French
Riviera right at a school largely
because it made me look so cool to my
classmates just turned out that I got
lucky find a place that shares your
values that has people you like and
respect and I'd say importantly that is
likely to grow and be profitable a lot
of opportunities come out of growth and
profit word about profits don't be
embarrassed by making significant
profits they're a measure of how well
you serve customers and how you add
value
you'll always be working for customers
be grateful for that accountability
in your life don't a lot of people think
well if I can become powerful if I can
get to a level then I'm no longer
accountable which is maybe this lack of
inhibitions that Deborah talked about go
early or stay late but not both and not
all the time
borrowing from the golf couplet about
putting and driving in the workplace
early is fordo latest for show early
morning hours you'll get lots done
you'll organize your day you can do
things when others aren't around late or
opportunities for socializing and
wrapping up the day both have their
places you can do both but just don't do
them all the time or you'll burn out and
your wear out everybody else in the
organization be entrepreneurial in
spirit
in other words learn how to control and
manage assets or to access and direct
resources and assets that you don't
control learn how to manage through
influence and not more formal Authority
I think I was really lucky in starting
out in the real estate industry because
you're always dealing with a virtual
organization you're not the boss of
anybody then think like an owner manager
even though you don't own the firm to
run a P&L recognize that you'll be hired
for the skills you learned here and
you'll be fired for your behavior or
limited by your behavior in most cases
the behavior that will limit you will
have a whole lot to doing what you
should have learned with not doing what
you should have learned at your mother's
name when you go ship when you negotiate
make sure you're not the only winner
it's good to understand anchoring
positioning you know first offer zero
some prisoners dilemmas and all the
things you learn about negotiating here
but the best and most durable agreements
in life depend on trust and goodwill so
consider your negotiations as a set of
reasonable conversations that merely
have the very awkward format of a
counter of offer counteroffer
and finally recognize that not all the
negotiations matter
you want to lose some negotiations
especially with your spouse's and your
children and business partners never try
to go to the documents to resolve a
disagreement don't worry about pleasing
others at all costs at the early stages
of your life you're more likely to want
to please others it's better to be
restrict respected and trusted than to
be loved if you're respected and trusted
you may eventually be loved if however
you're loved without respect or trust
you'll eventually be abandoned betrayed
they mistreated and that will have a lot
of effects in your life we're looking
for good people in your business don't
keep hiring yourself or just relying on
resumes that look good and impressive
embrace opportunities to sacrifice
giving up things that matter to you for
things that matter more is the key to
caring to passion to love and to success
simply put we love those things and
people for which we sacrifice yes if you
don't believe that think how you feel
about the GSB after spending two years
and 19 thousands of dollars here you
care about it oh yeah
as a manager learn to fly at 30,000 feet
and it's strafing level then do both
don't fixate as far as Tam management be
early give yourself artificial deadlines
sleep on decisions spend lots of time
listening to others manage by wandering
around don't simply manage your inbox
and outbox most of the business issues
that you'll encounter need to be
anticipated before they'll and fully
developed on your desk let me just wrap
up here quickly a couple of things on
change and conflict these are some of
the things you really have to manage
don't fear change or conflict is it as a
new manager those are things you tend to
like to avoid respect them both as
worthy of your best care and your
deepest thought choose carefully what
you change people don't like change and
when you make a change make sure you're
moving toward something rather than away
from a problem you're moving towards an
objective not away from so many changes
are made when people see a problem they
change things to get away from the
problem make changes sooner than later
keep it simple and I'd say just in
general I was with Rama Sharon who's a
famous author and coach and he said
basically that boards really can only
remember and work on three or four
things and you just need to stay with
those headlines so learn to write
one-page memos learn to develop six
dialed dashboards learn to have three or
four headlines and everything you do
when you make a change that doesn't work
quickly admit it accept blame move on
when you make one that does work
allocate the credit to others and
celebrate it with them so far as
conflict understand its nature if the
conflict is over values get out if the
conflict is over goals consider
compromise and if the conflict is over
means embrace it you'll learn from it
you'll synergize because business is a
competitive sport it will be easy to get
the competitive juices flowing and to
allow that get the better up to get the
better of you don't allow room for
grudges bitterness anger or desire for
retribution no matter how irrational it
may seem it's in your long-term best
interest to let go protect and develop
your own brand your brand is your
promise it's what people can rely on
when dealing with you great brands are
extraordinarily valuable but they're one
way sticky takes years to build them up
through action after action after action
and they can be destroyed with a single
act don't miss the chance in your first
job to set up your own baseline set your
baseline communications so you don't
need to throw tantrums to show your
upset
curse to make memorable your points or
show wild exuberance to show you're
pleased if you fail to set this
reasonably calm baseline as a manager
your manic-depressive fluctuations will
drive everybody nuts and limit your
effectiveness along these lines develop
a world-class temperament this often
starts with repeating to yourself
it's not about me now you've been living
in a world where it is about you you've
been feeding yourself you've been
gaining skills it has been about you but
just as it was a shock to medieval man
to have Copernicus and Galileo Galileo
show that the earth was not the center
of the universe it is a shock to some to
get out there and realize that they are
not the center of decisions how they
feel and care about things you'll grow
from removing yourself from the center
well we may not like it that our planet
occupies an obscure corner in one of 250
million galaxies we really resent it
and take it personally that it
stubbornly continues to result revolve
around the Sun whether or not we're
there but it does management consists of
dealing with a series of problems the
higher you go the thorny are the
problems the tougher ones don't yield to
the sorts of analyses that you've
learned here at the GSB most of the
really tough ones yield if at all to
things like character character values
integrity trust information kindness
patience listening tough mindedness that
may offend persistence fearlessness
determination character traits prepare
for adversity or failure just don't let
it be terminal if you've failed at
something if you haven't failed at
something you haven't been trying hard
enough
you've batted a thousand to get in here
very few of you have very many failures
remember you get into the American
Baseball Hall of Fame if you about 300
that's getting a hit thirty percent of
the time so if you're not trying things
and not succeeding at them in business
you're probably not trying hard enough
see your reversals as opportunities to
learn to take action to reveal character
or give you something to work on your
your trustworthiness will ever be
measured
against how you handle things when the
chips are down under adversity under
pressure I won't go through all the
things that you should expect there as
you come to understand your core values
and where you'll draw the bright lines
state them in a way that others can
understand them Peter Drucker said the
following whenever anyone goes to his or
her associates and says this is the
contribution
I plan to concentrate on and the results
I should be expected to deliver the
response is always the underlines always
why didn't you tell me earlier
because Trust is so hard to build and so
easy to destroy and so nearly impossible
to repair its treated as your most
precious asset it will become your most
important currency and I was just
mentioning to Debra here afterward that
I think you will feel powerful if you
know your core values if you have
integrity around them and if you have
trust relationships with people that in
and of itself that equation is
empowering whether or not you are have
titler authority within an organization
building trust is hard work
people can't trust you your ability to
lead them will be limited to where they
would go without you they will be like
you will be like actually finding a
parade and getting in front of it and
that will reduce you to a political
calculus that will corrupt you and deny
you the sense of accomplishment as a
leader over the long run so if you'd be
happy if you'd enjoy peace and
well-being and if you'd find profound
and lasting success make make a
difference in the life of another person
forget man too kind it is an abstraction
make a difference in the life of another
and build something that outlasts you
remove obstacles that trip others up and
provide insight and create new value all
these activities and focuses and
ambitions are more rewarding than
monetary success or fame although the
latter often come with those who can do
that
you've been in a safe port here you're
getting ready to set sail I'm living
proof that you'll survive whatever
storms come your way and that anyone
underlined any one of you can flourish
if you work hard or true to your core
values and never violate another's trust
with that I wish you Godspeed and open
the Florida questions for the last
couple of minutes
any questions yeah please on why we
should mistrust those who are not
powerful
we're not powerful because they can't
deliver you know if I if I tell my
partner who's a lawyer and a very
capable guy very high character
extraordinarily competent that I would
like to put it in his hands to keep me
from paying capital gains tax this year
I really don't want to pay capital gains
tax and I really trust him to keep me
from having to do it he's smart we can't
deliver he it doesn't have the power to
change the law and so a lot of times we
see these high character high competence
people and we trust them but they're not
in a position to deliver any more than
my wife is in a position to fly that 747
so you really have to in a sense if you
don't want to have that kind of naive
trust that will betray you in the end
and that may make you feel angry at the
world don't be so naive as to trust
people that don't have the power to
deliver so if you then would be
trustworthy have character competence
and power or you can't be trusted so
don't be afraid of this this power I
mean I think being powerful and it can
come with this incredible calm you have
from knowing values but be powerful do
not feel unempowered and then I think
what never talked about about acting in
this way that sort of flaunts power by
acting in a dissonant by my partner that
would lie down on the floor and make me
talk to him on the floor that is a silly
display and are usually a quite an
insecure display of power so
I would say decade is at the outer edge
but if you do think about this comment
you made is you are never in balance at
every moment of your life you're out of
balance because you can't be doing
everything you want to do at the same
time so you are always balancing and now
the question is just what rhythm what
pace do you want to make sure that you
exercise every day every two hours every
week every month whatever so and it's
all these priorities all these values
that you have in your life you're gonna
have to let them get out of balance and
it's a question of how long I think I
went about as long as anybody being out
of balance and I don't I'm not proud of
it I do think that it helped me achieve
certain things I would not have achieved
otherwise and I have made up for it I
paid price where I but I'm the same kind
I'm the same guy that promised my wife
if she would marry me I would learn how
to dance
and she came to me about five years ago
and said you know I'd kinda like to cash
in on that it's been 34 years and I said
yeah I never told you when so I mean I
have an ability to stay out of balance
for a pretty long time and I don't
recommend it I think it costs those you
care about but but I do think at the
beginning of your career you really
ought to think about managing that to be
a little longer than maybe you're
comfortable with
I think work-life balance is an
important thing but it you do have to be
careful with it yeah
right well I think I'm the integrity and
value to me values are those things that
you cannot compromise and I also think
the values are not virtues you know
sometimes people think values are these
high-minded things that we have to live
up to I think about business values have
to do for me with making a profit making
a profit every quarter you know
celebrating success growing the business
at a certain getting a return on capital
that exceeds the cost of capital I mean
some kind of basic things those are
important business values so I think you
can kind of compartmentalize those so if
you have people in your organization
that don't buy into the set of values
that are relevant for that organization
they are you need to leave because you
cannot compromise values so I mean you
can discuss them you can understand you
can come to a meeting of the minds on
them but if you really are at variance
there might my view is often those
deteriorate into litigation or worse
worse I guess being violence or
something but one last question and yeah
that's a great question I think you
never quite fully trust again when
somebody has betrayed that trust so I
tend to then make agreements and sort of
nail things down more carefully I'm
always a bit wary and a bit cautious
when Trust has been violated it's very
hard to repair it is one of the
stickiest things one way sticky long
time to build short time to it so I I
would say that in an ideal world you
would keep forgiving and and you know
help people get better I find as a
manager though there's too much at stake
there's too many other people relying on
things so that to deal with
untrustworthy people or people some but
he's violated trust I have to move on so
I think you have to be pretty tough
minded about it as a manager with your
children you just keep forgiving them
right and vice versa come on any events
great to be with you thank you